بسبب تقلب الاسواق الماليه العالميه
والاوضاع الاقتصاديه الصعبه بانج كولمان
سكس الامريكي يتجه الى الاستغناء عن اكثر
من ثلاثه الاف ومئتين وظيفه في عمليه تعد
من اعماق واكبر عمليات التسريح التي قام
بها البنك في تاريخه الحديث وفقه ما كشفت
طبعا بلومبرج مجموعه جولدن رفضت التعليق
على الموضوع ولكن صحيفه
الامريكيه اكدت الامر مشيره الى ان عمليات
التسريح ستحصل في غضون ايام وستؤثر على
معظم الاقسام الرئيسيه للبنوك ومن المتوقع
ان تركز على قسم الخدمات المصرفيه
الاستثماريه والتخفيضات ستمثل نحو سته فصل
خمسه بالبيئه من القوى العامله البالغ
عددها تسعه واربعين الفا وهي اقل من
سيناريو الاسوء المتمثل بثلاثه الاف 1900
وظيفه
[موسيقى]